in indonesia's north kalimantan region
palm oil farmers prepare for business as
usual as an export ban comes to an end
the export ban caused a huge loss for us
the price fell so low it really hits us
farmers
indonesia is the world's largest palm
oil producer palm oil exports had been
banned for three weeks as a way to help
ease domestic problems with the price
and availability of cooking oil while
there's been rising international demand
the government will also reintroduce a
domestic market obligation for palm oil
producers forcing them to sell their
products locally at a set price
from what we've seen in the field the
price of bulk oil is slowly declining as
the cooking oil supply is becoming more
abundant
experts criticized the export ban as
misguided
it also set a precedence a very negative
precedence to other producer countries
if they
they have some difficulties in the
domestic market they just cut off the
export or ban the export then
it would make the global food security
is in disarray
farmers held regular protests against
the export ban and say the government
needs to find a better solution in the
future
so we see that there is a mistake made
in the chain of distribution it seems
like this country didn't realize that
cooking oil is a primary need meanwhile
they give it to all private sector
like millions around the world
indonesians are noticing they're paying
more for the essentials shoppers and
business owners say the volatility of
food prices is making life harder for
them cooking oil prices have fallen
since the export ban was introduced but
they're still higher than the prices
people are used to
the government had initially planned to
keep the export ban in place until
prices reached 96 cents per litre that
target has not yet been met
we had to raise our prices because the
price of meat is going up and the price
of cooking oil is still up it's very
difficult for us
the government says it will continue to
monitor prices to make sure indonesians
can afford the essentials but many here
say they are already struggling
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta